we have been given this rectangular grid
of paths with this being the starting
point and this being the destination
Zara's at the starting point and wants
to reach the cake shop which is at the
destination think of these lines as
paths Zara can take to travel to the
cake shop with this we have been asked
for the number of different shortest
paths Zara can take to reach the cake
shop this is the typical permutations
and combinations problem you see in the
competitive exams sometimes we don't
even realize that it's a permutations
and combinations problem are we asked to
select or arrange objects no then how is
it a permutations and combinations
problem read the question again the
number of shortest paths shortest is the
key word here we have been asked to
select the shortest path how do we find
the number of shortest paths before you
start thinking let me tell you the worst
thing you could possibly do manually
count the shortest paths don't even
think of making that mistake as you will
end up losing a lot of time now to find
the shortest path we first need to
understand what the shortest path is
many students assume that going to the
right and then straight up is one of the
shortest paths and the other is going
straight up to the right to reach the
destination these are the two shortest
paths students directly think of they
assume all other paths are longer to
know if this is true let's take a random
path from inside right up right up right
up right up and right we covered nine
units lengths when we took this path
let's take another random path up up
right right up right up right right
again nine units now let's look at the
earlier path that had crossed our minds
as the shortest paths right right right
right right up up up and up again nine
units
we had also thought of up up up up right
right right right and right the shortest
path will cover nine units that's our
conclusion we will come back to this
point but let's answer a question that
some of y'all would be wondering about
what is not a shortest path the answer
is simple
at any point if you travel left or down
it will not be a shortest path so you go
right up left up up up right right right
right and right this will be 11 units
and it's clearly longer than 9 it's
because we took a left here
the same logic applies if we go down up
up right down right right right right up
up and up 11 units more than 9 so for
the shortest paths we can either travel
right or up not left or down now going
back to a previous point the shortest
part will cover 9 units what does this 9
it is the sum of the number of columns
and the number of rows yes this grid has
5 columns 1 2 3 4 & 5 and it has 4 rows
1 2 3 & 4 5 plus 4 is 9 so now you know
what a shortest path is now let's move
on to solving the problem in every case
we saw Zara had to move 5 units to the
right and 4 units up the sum of these
two is 9 units so looking at this can we
say that out of the nine units Zara
travels to reach the destination five
have to be rightwards
yes we can say that out of the nine
units for any shortest part we have to
select five which go to the right so 9c
5 will give us the number of shortest
paths Zara can take to reach the
destination wait can we also say that
out of the nine units Zara takes for the
shortest path 4 have to be upwards yes
9c 4 will also give us the same answer
these 2 will be equal
in case you're unable to recollect the
formula for NCR is n factorial divided
by R factorial times n minus R factorial
this will equal 9 factorial divided by 5
factorial times 9 minus 5 factorial and
this will be 9 factorial divided by 4
factorial times 9 minus 4 factorial same
answer 126 different shortest paths
Zarah can take to reach the destination
okay we have the answer now but is there
another interesting way to arrive at
this answer can we use another approach
we have used before think could you
think of anything okay so we know that
zahra will be moving 5 units to the
right and 4 units upwards we know that
for sure no matter which shortest path
she takes it will be total of 9 units
out of which 5 will be to the right and
4 will be upwards so we write our five
times and you four times this is what we
need to arrange all possible
arrangements of these nine letters will
give us the number of different shortest
paths Sara can take this should remind
you of the anagram problem we had solved
we had the word excessive as there were
nine letters we wrote 9 factorial e was
present thrice hence divided this by 3
factorial s was present twice hence
divided again by 2 factorial we applied
the same logic here as there are nine
letters present we write nine factorial
R appears five times so divide this by 5
factorial and as u appears four times we
divide this by 4 factorial this also
gives us the same answer all three give
us the answer as 126 zahra can take 126
different shortest paths to reach the
gate shop you may use any method you
like depends on what you are comfortable
with but make sure you understand the